Hi.
I'm Jeffrey Sham
with the Google
Developer Relations Team.
In this video, I'll show you
how to get started with the
DoubleClick For Publishers API
PHP Client Library, from
downloading the code to running
examples, and also
tips like what has changed in
the login configuration and
where to find the log files.
For new users, I'd recommend
taking a look at the Getting
Started Guide.
Here you will find resources
for account signup, setup
information for different
programming languages, as well
as other developer resources.
From here we will navigate to
client libraries and start
from the QuickStart Guide
provided for PHP.
One of the first things you need
to do is make sure your
system meets the requirements
to use the client library.
For PHP, we need Version 5.2
with date of sub-client, and
the sub-client, openness to
cell, and curl extensions.
So let's go ahead and download
the client library
from the code site.
This is the project homepage for
the client library, and it
contains up-to-date
information on version releases.
You can go to the Wiki tab for
additional information, Issues
tab for bug tracking, and Source
tab for instructions on
how to check out the code
through a version control
system, or just to view
the code online.
Now let's go to Downloads and
get the most recent version of
the client library.
The most current library
will have the
featured library label.
So we click on the file link.
Wait for the download
to finish.
Click on the download so it
unpacks, and we're almost
ready to run some code.
For setup, we go to our client
library directory, and then go
to /src/Google/Api/
Ads/Dfp/auth.ini.
And we open that up to put
in our information.
Choose Client Login.
All we have to do is fill in
the email and password.
It's good practice to have an
application name, and the
network code has to be filled
in if the user is associated
with more than one network.
With the file saved, our
setup is now complete.
Let's take a look at the
examples, which are organized
by version and then
by service.
Looking at Creative Service,
you can see that there are
seven examples that
we can run.
Let's take a closer look
at the Get Creatives
By Statement example.
You can open the PHP file with
an editor of your preference,
but I'd like to show you how
to view this file online
through the Client Library
Project Site.
So we go to Source, Browse,
Examples, choose our version,
our service, and finally,
pick our example.
You will notice that many of the
examples, like this one,
will have a pattern of creating
a DFP user, using it
to create a service, and
then using a service
to make an API call.
In this case, we create a DFP
user with no arguments.
So we just post the credentials
from the auth.ini
that we configured earlier.
We use the Filter Statement with
bind variables to specify
that we only want up to
500 Image Creatives.
We call Get Creatives By
Statements on the service with
the statement object, and we
display the results, one line
per creative, to the
command line.
Now let's run this example
and see what we get.
To do this, we just have to
type php GetCreativesBySt
atementExample.php
and hit Enter.
And there we go.
We've successfully retrieved
some image creatives.
You can find out more
information about the request
from the logs in the
Logs Directory.
The Request ID here is really
useful for troubleshooting if
you've ever run into problems,
and you'd like to post a
question on the forum for us.
You can also configure
the level of
logging that you want.
By default, the library captures
each request into the
Request Info XML.
Let's change our logging to
capture the SOAP Request and
SOAP Response Log as well.
Going back to the command
line, we can
run the example again.
Great, the request
is finished.
And looking at the Log Directory
again, we see now
that there is a soap_xml.log
file.
Looking at the log file, you
can see the tail end of the
XML response for the Get
Creatives By Statement call we
made just now.
So what does it look like
if we run into an error?
Let's try it out by changing
our filter field to an
incorrect value.
Running the example again, this
is what we'll see in the
Request Info Log.
We see that the last call has
failed from the isFault=1.
And the Error Details tells us
that there was a problem with
our filter statement.
And that's all there is to
getting started with the PHP
Client Library.
We have a number of resources
available to help you,
including these documentations,
FAQs, blogs,
forums, and developer
hangouts.
I hope you enjoyed the
streamcast and would love to
discuss more through any
of these channels.
Just let us know.